ich habe hier gerade in LA vielleicht
zufällig den besten Bagel meines Lebens
gefunden wir sind hier gerade in Studio
City sind an der Straße vorbeigefahren
haben diesen food Truck stehen sehen der
einfach nur Bagels verkauft wunderschön
Design und man weiß einfach dass sie gut
sind wir haben uns für den lockberagy
entschieden relativ klassisch und für
den chedy Web und jetzt lass uns
probieren das ist der Lock Bagel ein
Klassiker sesambagel cream cheese
Frühlingszwiebeln rote Zwiebeln und
natürlich Lachs ein paar Kern sind auch
noch mit dabei und es sieht einfach nur
wunderschön aus alter W fast mein Leben
vorbeigegangen let
try schon die Tomate darauf ist perfekt
ist einfach ein absoluter Klassiker in
Perfektion weiter geht's mit dem chedy
Web in der Option make it heavy das
heißt das noch ein Hash Brown also ein
kartoffelröst die drauf kommt heavy
sieht es aus aber lassen wir es uns
schmecken m mhm bacen Ei Käse auf einem
plin Bagel so könnte jeder Tag beginnen